tout est isabelle ou isabello bon
mathieu on le redit lors desquelles je
vous avez perdu votre virginité votre
virginité
alors vous franchement pas contrairement
à ce que vous pouvez penser à la 19 ans
19 jeux je jure je gère elle s'appelait
comment way science fiction mais je sais
plus mais pas très belle ah oui non mais
naïve au calage jamais chez moi à 18 ans
n'a eu comme personne vous a trouvé un
garçon qui s'appelait personnes
s'étaient pas que david non c'est pas le
propre de ce qui a nom et qui alors il
n'y avait plus et qui s'appelait il vous
fait un prénom
oui eric owens ont fait quatre saisons
oui laurence je crois expérience moyenne
qui a été crescendo après away ben ammar
était beau à voir s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît et isabelle mois 19 ans
j'avais dit que je fis de passer de
bacary et c'était le mec le monsieur de
46 ans exactement à exactement qui nous
regardent de là-haut qu'on embrasse
ça va jean-michel mais un gros 16 un
petit set je me suis à plus exactement
j'étais en seconde on parle pas de la
taille tu appelles 18 ans et demi la
loose
non alors à qui n'ont pas pu car dit
monsieur à royan je faisais de la radio
et j'avais la clé de la radio et parce
que quand on est jeune c'est l'endroit
qui pose problème ce oui c'est vrai et
j'avais les clés de la radio il a été
sur la moquette
non et ça m'a tout évidemment je ne sais
pas j'ai pas vu la marque ça n'a pas
duré extrêmement longtemps mais en fait
et je n'avais jamais découverte
c'est la première fois oui et je me suis
dit ça fait étranger en fait je me suis
brûlé tout l'arrière du dos et les
genoux n'aura pas d'effets non mais lol
et des jambes
ah oui ce que j'étais en position je
fais rien c'était la dame qui avait plus
d'expérience on est d'accord à oui ok je
me frotte pas mais je bouger un petit
peu
non parce que je suis très inquiet si
vous aviez les genoux mais sans riches
ou non non non les châteaux si tu fais
rien comment tu souffres les genoux à
l'envers mais pas les genoux elle à
l'arrière le coche et très surdotées
isabelle ou isabello bon mathieu on leur
dit j'avais 16 ans pierre antoine et
antoine ahua antoine ils doivent avoir
une belle chute et ben oui mais pierre
antoine jeta pas de mèche pour faire
c'est vrai qu'il avait une grande mer
bien sûr elle ça a été ma bobonne grande
magie amour oui la non alors il avait
une très grande mèche bon ah ouais si on
suit dit on veut pas le savoir tous des
mèches comme ça ah bah écoute et
benjamin sa coiffure
c'était avec une dame
non c'était un karatéka ne and on and
has
c'est l'excusé one voilà au moins on
n'en est pas là dedans aussi
alors n'oubliez pas je suis comme votre
papa et son papa on n'imagine jamais en
train de faire l'amour c'est ça ouais
bah non alors bientôt avec chacun des
sexes vas-y dis nous je vous ai expliqué
que je n'ai jamais franchi la barrière
du rubicon 20 microns oui moi je vous le
dis ah non j'ai jamais touché asie là tu
viens tu as de relancer son intérêt là
là là je le prenais jamais touché un
zizi autre que le bien et ça ne risque
pas d'arriver je vous le dis je prends
ça comme un cactus j'ai peur que ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]